thank you
[Music]
hey Jason are you are you a Kanye West
fan
I like uh his shoes
and also uh that's the first thing
you like the shirts the new shirts the
White lives matter shirts no you're not
a fan why not you don't think White
lives matter we have a white person in
here White lives matter you matter oh
okay I matter but not all the white
people not all whites just not all white
people about it so
so Kanye recently uh released a new
30-minute documentary called last week
which captures footage of a moment where
he was meeting with two Adidas
Executives uh and on at one point during
the uh they say Frosty exchange yay
whips out his phone and starts playing a
clip from a porno shoving his screen
into an executive's face in an attempt
to strengthen his argument which porno
was it what kind of argument was it
let's let's watch this clip together
just uh
[Music]
come on keep going keep going before we
lose that I'm gonna [ __ ] play music
that we can't oh here it is
thank you
again
[Music]
oh so he's not showing the porno part
he's showing the [ __ ] storyline yeah
that accent dude the guy with a Bosnian
exit
come on that's very good
he said oh come on man was he putting up
to his face so he can hear is he placing
the speaker in his ear I think he's just
Enthusiast he's literally shown like
he's showing the [ __ ] screens like
hey look look look look check it out oh
yeah I mean that doesn't sound like it's
in the thick of things and the thicker
things I imagine it was the exchange
like an opening plot Point yeah he said
he's got the same voice doesn't he the
rapper can be heard saying as he shows
the two men the clip is this a porn
movie The Man then asks before yay moves
the camera close to his face quote he's
got a northern European accent the exact
objects noting that their voices don't
sound very similar at all as everybody
sits around uncomfortably Jesus Christ
come on man the executive says after a
few moments and swats away yay's phone
in an attempt to get get the meaning
back on track
elsewhere throughout the meeting which
features several cuts the rapper points
to a man with a blurred out face and
says I'm only going to work at Adidas if
he's the CEO quote you guys have done
wrong by the company by the business and
by the partnership he added quote the
whole concept of this porn video is that
the guy had cheated so then the girl is
like well I'm going to do the thing
that's your worst nightmare this is your
worst nightmare he says pointed
dramatically at his pick for CEO whoa oh
that's a weird one and this is Kanye's
Kanye released this documentary yeah he
showed this clip of that moment
that's so weird they did that does it
count as sexual harassment if you force
someone to view a porno right a little a
little bit no there's a bunch of guys
you're all good dude if it's guy to guy
you're all good because you know like if
you show your dick that's [ __ ]
obviously harassment but if you show
another person's dick via screen I think
I think you'd be fine
oh that's fine I think so you should be
if it's got a guy I think yeah even a
stranger like somebody you don't know
question yeah you got one of these right
here yeah because the guy that you show
the porno to say I didn't know Bart I'm
on a I'm on a bus with Barton on my uh
check this out I'm like yeah yeah watch
this and he goes Jesus okay that's
pretty good yeah yeah see but if it's
sexual harassment to airdrop a dick
isn't it the same thing see is it
my Stop's getting off right can I get my
money too much
so one of uh one of yay's Associates
chimes in to clarify uh Kanye's remarks
following the outburst and says quote
what you're feeling right now is Extreme
discomfort and that is exactly the point
because when someone steals this man's
ideas his Creations it's like you're
stealing a child oh so that okay I get
it now the motivation to show him that
is to make him feel the feeling that
he's trying to use it as a reference and
specifically in the porn it was a
cheating thing or something right that's
kind of which is you can't do that I
don't think
that doesn't sound right I don't think
you can do that and he said these are
all children of his mind you've
kidnapped them basically talking about
their brand partnership and how Adidas
stole Creations from Kanye and so that's
his that's his way of getting this point
across to executives to get the CEO that
they all don't like yeah point to the
executives and show this is this is how
you're making me feel by showing them
[ __ ] cheating porno and then pointing
to another exact thing like that's the
guy I think should be the CEO I don't
think it's that that bad
the porno thing or the porno thing
why why not please because there's like
what what happened nothing happened I
just show you and I'm like look this is
I feel bad the guy who shows his dick to
his friends I guess that would be so bad
that was in an old video Colleen he's a
changed man he's changed that was so 45
minutes ago yeah I really like the uh I
love seeing corporate people suddenly
gets so appalled yeah
you watch porn the fact he goes porn
movie yeah Jesus Christ I don't like
that [ __ ] either that's lame dude yeah
just be like that's a test that's how I
feel about penis too it's like we all
have one but not to women yeah well not
not the woman find some dissimilarities
between mine and someone else's
you get confused easily I'm like did you
step in my own dick
like you said yeah so I feel like it's
really weird when you show it and
they're like oh my God this is
harassment it's like no I'm just this is
also art hey that's true that's true
it's subjective there are some French
films that are worse than pornos well I
guess um just uh to play fair in this
executive uh situation I feel like
there's almost like codes of conduct
when you're going to that space right
when you're if you're specifically
meeting with executive business people
of a like yeah in the way you would look
at a Fortune 500 Fortune whatever
company I feel like there's like known
codes of conduct like how you dress but
obviously I also understand that like
Yay the the echelon that he's at even in
his own mind carries his own code of
content yeah yeah you know he can walk
into a place and like that that place
just changes right whereas when we were
talking about like Will Smith slapping
Chris Rock it's like you can't do that
at that event yeah the Oscars is known
to have a type of ways there's a certain
way if you did Dustin on the street you
know what I mean like that would just be
regular entertainment yeah maybe a
lawsuit yeah
for Kanye to the reason why he's showing
the porno to these execs is not harass
them but it's to illustrate a point of
how he's feeling which I feel like
showing a porno is a little unnecessary
for the scenario that he's trying to
give up if you could describe how you
feel but like I said he comes with his
own code of conduct right like did his
tactic work I don't think it did I think
he got the opposite effect they're like
yo this dude is crazy tactic was just to
do something that's so outrageous that
eventually people will notice it in the
future I feel like he's so outrageous
already he like does crazy [ __ ] so I I
think it's crazy that if people are
surprised that see he's like wearing
Crazy Shirts right on brand yeah yeah
because I think like two and so that
world is for sure crazy not like
excusing it or whatever I've never
really been in that world before the
closest I've been is when me and Joe uh
got the Living Color part and then
randomly we get phone calls from like
all the agencies caawme and all this
stuff and then our first ever like
Crossing YouTube into Hollywood like
territory
um Taylor Lautner who was really big at
the time Twilight his agent was we had a
meeting with him so we come into this
room and it's like this big big ass long
[ __ ] Jesus last supper looking table
and all the other agents are there the
booking agent like the book agent the
[ __ ] like uh syndicated like TV
series agent like all the whole agents
are there except for the agent me and
Joe come in we're doing small talk and
then this guy comes in like all [ __ ]
flamboyant and [ __ ] and then he just
sits in his chair like
like he's like he's dressed nicely but
just an extremely esoteric way of
Behaving right like Kanye style of this
and I was like oh [ __ ] this is the [ __ ]
you see in the movies he comes in and
he's just like all right so who are
these guys and then like oh those are
the guys that uh were on YouTube it just
nailed uh the analytic color audition
and he goes wait from YouTube bye
and he just walks out of the room
like like it was like YouTube but didn't
didn't wasn't matched up to his [ __ ]
level and everyone was like yo that guy
and so me and Joe are like oh [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] but then like in that world
like you're saying everyone has their
code of conduct so even agents that are
at a top level they can walk into a room
and completely change that's true it's
like whatever position you're in you
kind of can rewrite the rules exactly
yeah and I was like what which is the
rule you know what I mean that's true
that's a really good way to put it the
code of contact everybody has a code of
conduct and changing it yeah it's like
when Steve walks I just want a picture
he walks in here with his two-piece
Justice yeah exactly when he's got a
[ __ ] light at 11 15. yeah and his
sunglasses and then when he comes in I'm
in my head I'm like I got a Rebrand dude
all right the white t-shirts aren't
doing it he might show you a [ __ ]
porno these Kirkland signatures aren't
doing it the white way never talk [ __ ]
on Craigslist I can't compete I already
had a Rebrand I feel like before you
were just wearing like what was it like
yay gay slay or whatever that was my
shirt just like pink tank tops and like
really short shorts and women's shoes
and now I feel like you're like you're a
fighter you're like you compete you were
wearing women's shoes yeah yeah I didn't
know you were hey I told you guys I was
wearing women's shoes and confidence and
then you guys and you guys uh like like
what kind of are you talking about like
like they're just women's size or are
they like oh you said in confidence I
thought you were confident about your
women's shoes no I'm not confident in
anything but we should end the video
foreign